senior Analyst at McKenzie intelligence
Services Stuart Ray hi again Stuart now
I know that you've been examining these
satellite images what's happening in
maripole and what we're seeing the
Russians consolidating their position in
maripole tidying up getting rid of the
the buildings that have been demolished
and are unsafe they're being raised to
the ground now and there's been some
fresh construction such as we're seeing
on the screen here this is very
interesting this obviously clearly
states or clearly shows the Russian's
intent that they're not going anywhere
they're building some pretty pretty
impressive infrastructure in that City
what we're seeing here on this one um
I've been looking at the imagery and
previous images to see the development
of this service facility this looks like
a kind of a warehouse facility probably
a logistics storage Depot or what have
you and the building to the uh to the
the left here looks like some kind of
headquarters um we've got some pretty
good security fencing around there we
can see the lighting on the security
fencing and over just to above the
building there we've got a separate
world or offense compound it looks like
to me like underground fuel storage
possibly for like heating oil or what
have you in in that facility a Commons
Tower I won't have you in there
um I think this is a headquarters
building of some kind possibly not
necessarily military uh we've got the
ornamental trees placed around to make
it look pleasing so it's quite an
interesting facility that they're
building there in amongst Residential
Properties obviously that's obviously
causes a headache if it's going to be
targeted for a military strike yeah but
what can we discern from it I mean we
can see what they're building but what
does it mean it's them consolidating
their position and garrisoning the town
bring in more Security in there there is
a kind of
um there is a partisan operation by the
ukrainians that are in mariopol against
the the Russian forces in there what is
surprising is the security awareness
facility is
um weaker than I would expect
considering the environment they're in I
would expect in the British army of an
example if we're in a place like this we
would have much more security probably
you know enforce guard posts along the
fence line to actually secure that but
it's it's a statement of intent that the
Russians aren't going anywhere and
they're garretting the city to to you
know fully occupy it let's talk about
the city of bakmut which we know has
become an important symbol hasn't it for
some of the uh some of the Russian
troops to try and demonstrate to Putin
what they have been able to capture
what's happening there yeah bakma is
it's operationally strategically it's
not massively important but it is
symbolic they've invested a lot of
resources Manpower and Equipment into
trying to take backwards but
impressively the ukrainians have managed
to resist up until now we're seeing um
probably an attempt to encircle the time
of bakmut uh with an axis coming from
the south and from the North Tryon
circular more gains although slight in
the sound to take back but what it does
it shows that the the investment of
resources has been for nothing it also
to a degree it protects their flank from
the Ukrainian counts offensive up in the
north and it opens up the the corridors
to move towards sloviansk and chromatos
which is obviously key in their aim to
take over the done it's oblast as part
of the donbass region
of course the other pressure that can be
brought to bear on Russia is financial
economic and let's talk about this price
cap that's been agreed by a number of
different countries on uh Russian crude
oil how is that going to affect Russia's
coffers to fund this war
um in the first place it's not going to
have a massive dramatic effect on it
it's not going to have a catastrophic
effect on their economy to support the
war it's going to be very difficult to
police it's up to the actual the
carriers of the crude oil to actually
confirm that the the end client has paid
the the correct uh price for for that
oil but obviously there are other state
actors that are going to buy all from
Russia at whatever price they want to
they're more aligned to Russia than you
are to the west and have a different
stance over the war in Ukraine so
there's going to be ways and means that
Russia will still be able to get revenue
from the South Royal but it will have a
slight impact on it but not the
catastrophic impact I think that it was
hoped because many of those countries
had already started getting their oil
from elsewhere that's right The Usual
Suspects that are Iran North Korea India
the place is starting to know are
probably having a completely different
stance to the war in Ukraine than the
West are
all right Stuart thank you very much in
indeed